I want you to be back today's may be
free I showed you this diagram as my
mechanism for convincing you that the
square of the sum is this thing rather
than just a square plus B Square which
is a very common mistake to make and you
can see why I did it not to maybe there
do you remember whether to a B what do
you say yeah it's those long rectangles
there right this one this one okay then
I posed the question to you just throw
it out there I said how would you
similarly convince someone of these to
which you've known for so long that
maybe you haven't thought about how to
prove to someone
does anyone have anywhere to run to you
at lunchtime anyone made sure okay well
if you need to run run but otherwise
I'll show you because so let me show you
show you how I'm gonna do this okay in
the same way as before the mood to begin
with a square but it's a slightly
different sweat so I'm gonna draw out
now in this case rather than making a
and B two lengths that are next to each
other the reason I did that with the
first program is because I'm adding a
and B it's a song but this time I'm
subtracting okay so rather than have any
and B and then add it together instead
what I'm gonna have these a going all
the way across the top there's a which
means I'm gonna have be kind of hanging
over there on the side just like before
but it's subtractive right so if this is
B where in my diagram is a minus B now
look it's just to the left right it's
this smaller square in here do you agree
with that so here is a minus B okay so a
minus B or square where is that but
carefully it's the top left square do
you agree with that if everything's all
symmetrical or nice then this guy here
is a minus B or square okay so now
engage your minds think we're if we now
matter where this is where are these
guys in the diagram well let's start
with the easy one where they swept the
whole thing a squared is the whole thing
so I'm saying to get to this square you
start with the big square a squared
now I'm gonna subtract to a B I will
whisk
where are the a B's in this diagram hmm
well the first one you can see is see
how this is B
well if this is B this is B do you agree
that this thing here is a B do you agree
hey me yes where's the other AP this the
tall one right it's this one there's
another a B right you start with your
big square then you take off this and
then you take off that but what have you
done you have taken away this guy which
is they sweat you take it away twice you
didn't mean to take away twice so what
should you do just add one back and
you're fine make sense all right this
last one is even more beautiful I need a
bit help look think this is my H squared
minus B squared
do you see it can you imagine this as a
squared minus B squared
look it's a square we think and I'll cut
out this part are you okay with that
okay now watch carefully right I want
you to think if this is a squared minus
B Square where is this
[Music]
there's a all the way across this little
guy over here is B right so where's a
minus B where is it as this two spots
you can pick anyone want to suggest yeah
yeah okay these sides here that connect
right this difference here is going to
be a minus B and it's also going to be
up here
do you agree okay so far so good so I've
got this shape that's the shape I can
see where that is here's the hard part
is that where is a plus B on this
diagram now the problem is unlike over
here where I have a and B adding
together a and B are never added
anywhere in this diagram at least not
yet
so a minus B down here right this is
also a minus B so do you agree that if I
slice this part
this height this height is the same as
that whiff do you agree okay so that
means if they're the same I can do that
right okay work that little piping out
the new hype because I turned it over
this height is also big and what was
this again a so he R is a plus B do you
see it a plus B a minus B tada
so I hope you enjoyed that